[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und marietta slomka
abend als sonst vor drei jahren in
downing street number 10 1 zog warteten
viele dass das nicht gut ausgehen werden
populisten könnten kampagne aber nicht
regieren das sah man bei jump das sah
man dann auf bei boris johnson die
entscheidende frage ist wie
zerstörerisch wirkt die populistische
regentschaft wie groß ist der
scherbenhaufen der zurückbleibt bei jump
ist er so riesig dass viele beobachter
um die demokratische zukunft der
vereinigten staaten fürchten bei boris
johnson dem notorischen spieler ist die
lage eine etwas andere zumal in seine
eigene partei vom hof gejagt aber auch
er wird ein erbe hinterlassen aus london
jetzt in hallein
nach all dem politischen drama von
gestern fragte sich am morgen nicht nur
larry der hauskater in number 10 downing
street was da heute wohl noch kommen
würde der politische scherbenhaufen den
johnson mit dem klammern an sein amt
angerichtet hatte war gewaltig
dem mann mit den mehr als sieben leben
vieles dann am mittag anheim der
inzwischen doch etwas verdutzten nation
zu erklären warum er sich so lange
dagegen gewehrt hatte sich dem
unvermeidlichen zu beugen
der grund warum ich so hart darum
gekämpft habe mein amt auf trag
weiterhin persönlich zu erfüllen ist
nicht weil ich es schlicht wollte
sondern weil ich dachte dies sei mein
job und meine pflicht ihnen gegenüber
ganz der alte also boris johnson wie man
ihn kennt selbst im moment des
niedergangs scheinbar unbeirrt immer
frontal durch die wand
zugegeben dass mit dem reck cit hat er
tatsächlich hingekriegt aber auf dem weg
dorthin und in der zeit danach hat er so
ziemlich alles in trümmer gelegt
britische wirtschaft die politische
moral im land und seine eigene karriere
fauxpas unfug skandal im skandal schien
schlicht an ihm abperlt sein talent
knifflige fragen einfach wegzugeben
ist eben so ausgeprägt wie seine
fähigkeit leute zum lachen zu bringen
alles inklusive sich selbst lächerlich
zu machen zog bei den humor verliebten
briten doch irgendwann war auch dem
letzten das lachen vergangen
party geht der skandal um mehrfaches
ungehemmtes feiern im regierungssitz
downing street während der rest der
nation im locker und zu hause
eingesperrt war und nicht einmal im
sterben liegende familienmitglieder
besuchen durfte war der anfang vom ende
die affäre um sexuelle belästigung
seitens eines parteifreundes den johnson
wider besseres wissen beförderte und
danach fälschlicherweise behauptet er
habe von dessen verfehlungen nichts
gewusst dann der tropfen der das fass
zum überlaufen brachte für die
opposition ist johnsons abgang zu wenig
und kommt zu spät
hat lyon betrug und chaos über das land
gebracht wir stecken fest mit einer
regierung die in diesen zeiten der
wirtschaftlichen krise nicht
funktionsfähig ist und alle die ihn
unterstützt haben sollten sich wirklich
schämen
zumal johnson ja noch eine weile als
premier weiter machen will so lange bis
ein nachfolger oder eine nachfolgerin
für den parteivorsitz der konservativen
gefunden ist der begriff lame duck die
sprichwörtliche lahme ente in der
politik muss ab heute wohl neu definiert
werden
für unsere londoner korrespondenten sind
das interessante zeiten andreas stamm
wir wissen ja politiker stürzen und der
regel nicht über einzelne affäre sondern
erst wenn sie den rückhalt der eigenen
leute verlieren was gab dafür jetzt bei
johnson den ausschlag
ja es ist wie immer ein bündel aber ich
glaube man kann guten gewissens zwei
hauptpunkte hervorheben zum ersten
zermürbung jeden tag mussten seine
minister raus und in immer höhere
schlagzahl absurdeste verteidigung
vortragen um die lügengebäude die boris
johnson dabei seinen skandalen aufbaute
irgendwie zu verteidigen das war
eigentlich immer nach demselben schema
tag eins der premierminister wusste von
nichts tag 2 er hat irgendwie gewusst
aber dann vergessen tag 3 ja so ähnlich
kann es dann gewesen sein aber genau
wissen wir es nicht und am tag 4 kam die
entschuldigung von boris johnson und das
hat viele zermürbt und das hat viele
dann wirklich mühe gemacht und der
zweite punkt ist vielleicht nicht
weniger wichtig boris johnson man wusste
um seine charakterlichen schwächen keine
frage aber er war ein wahlgewinner
zweimal bürgermeister in london in einer
linken statt als konservativer beim
rexit referendum hat er den ausschlag
gegeben dass das austritts lager
gewonnen hat und dann 2009/10 dieser
erdrutschsieg aber das ist vorbei er ist
zum ballast an der urne geworden es gab
hier zwei nach wahlen zum unterhaus vor
wenigen wochen waren krachenden
niederlagen mehr als ein denkzettel es
war ein johnson muss raus ruf der wähler
und wenn man dann noch überlegt dass die
nach wahlen stattfanden weil einer der
parlamentarier zurücktreten musste weil
er pornos im parlament geschaut hat und
der andere parlamentarier wegen
sexueller festigung eines minderjährigen
verurteilt wurde ich glaube dann hat man
ein gutes gefühl warum das heute hier
das letzte mal boris johnson war
zumindest als parteivorsitzender und
sein sein schicksal besiegelt ist das
ist ja dann die große frage wie es wie
es weiter geht also wenn er dann auch
als premierminister tatsächlich geht wie
wird das wetter gehen angesichts auch
dessen wie zerstritten seine partei zu
letzte auftrag
die partei ist immer noch zerstritten
vor allem heute die große frage wie kann
das denn sein dass er weiter die
regierungsgeschäfte führen kann nach all
dem was passiert ist das spaltet
durchaus die partei es scheint wohl
einen deal gegeben zu haben da mit
parteigrößen die eben ihm damit den
abschied auch ein wenig versüßt haben
aber es ist auch nicht ganz unüblich
denn wenn ein premierminister
zurücktritt so war es bei david cameron
2016 batterie summer 2009 10 dann
bleiben die geschäftsführend im amt es
wird keine großen vorhaben ergeben das
hat auch boris johnson heute klar
gemacht aber eben um die jetzt krisen zu
bekämpfen sind ja groß genug der krieg
in der ukraine
der in europa tobt dann die inflation
die hier auch steigt und steigt und der
explodierenden lebenshaltungskosten und
das ist eben der deal aber am ende des
tages wird dann jetzt ein klarer
strukturierten prozess eingeleitet
nächste woche gibt es den zeitplan wie
dann ein nachfolger eine nachfolgerin
bestimmt werden kann und dann ist boris
johnson geschichte vielleicht im oktober
vielleicht auch schon früher dann
übernimmt jemand anders aber das ist
eben unausweichlich wir sprechen von
september andreas tamme vielen dank
einen elefanten im raum kann man
übersehen bei einem real anwesenden
lavrov ist das schwieriger schon im
vorfeld ihrer reise wurde die deutsche
außenministerin vor allem gefragt wie
siehst du mit dem russen halten werden
wie trifft man auf jemanden ohne dass es
zu einem treffen kommt kunst der
diplomatie
die außenminister der g 20 bereiten auf
bali den gipfel im november vor den
umgang mit russland gerne auch gleich
schon mal üben wobei das vor allem ihr
ein problem für die westlichen
demokratien ist für viele andere
einschließlich der indonesischen
gastgeber ist die perspektive einer ganz
anderen
andreas künast hat die deutsche
außenministerin nach bali begleitet
als die indonesischen gastgeber der
deutschen außenministerin den roten
teppich ausrollen hat die delegation aus
berlin nicht nur 18 stunden flug hinter
sich sondern auch 14 tage grübelei
boykottieren konfrontieren ignorieren
hier kommt die antwort deutschland ist
da für indonesien ist dieser g20 gipfel
wichtig und indonesien ist für
deutschland wichtig für europa für den
westen aussenministerin massu die
schwankt zwischen der russischen und der
westlichen sicht wie so viele asiatische
staaten auf welche seite sich indonesien
schlägt betroffen ich bin hier als
deutsche außenministerin gemeinsam mit
meinen europäischen kollegen um deutlich
zu machen wir überlassen russland nicht
die internationale bühne wir stehen an
der seite der g 20 präsidentschaft hier
in indonesien eine absage ein boykott
hätte dem ansehen des westens in vielen
g20 staaten geschadet und russland in
die hände gespielt sergey lavrov ist
einer der ersten auf bali und fest
entschlossen nicht isoliert zu sein
lavrov trifft den türkischen lavrov
trifft den chinesischen außenminister
und herzt und scherzt als wäre alles wie
immer als hätte nicht er ganz persönlich
die welt man muss es so sagen belogen
wieder und wieder
noch in der woche vor dem einmarsch weiß
lavrov einmarsch gerüchte zurück all
diese szenarien sind komplett paranoid
nach dem einmarsch wirft lavrov der
ukraine russen verfolgung vor wie in
nazideutschen lassen die usa hätten ganz
europa unter ihre kontrolle des grafen
büro genauso wie
die ukraine sein andauernd damit
beschäftigt zu überlegen was sie
bestellen können und überhaupt die
ukraine niemand braucht die ukraine
herberg wird mit lawrow vreden im
konferenzraum wenn es sein muss ohne
handschlag ohne gruß
konferenz wo ich nicht lächelnd mit
jemand an der seite stehen kann der
zeitgleich die ukraine bombardiert
kinder erwachsene zivilisten kaltblütig
angreift deswegen wird es kein
offizielles foto auf diesem g20 treffen
geben als redner nummer 18 ist lavrov
angekündigt mit 19 3 mio für die anderen
und mit dem blick in die ukraine macht
jetzt hanna zimmermann weiter ja die
ukraine meldet auch heute russischer
angriffe im osten des landes vor allem
in den städten kammer torf und slogans
zudem schlugen russische raketen auf der
strategisch wichtigen schlangen insel im
schwarzen meer ein ukrainische soldaten
hatten nach der rückeroberung der insel
wieder die landesflagge hilft was sollen
diese bilder belegen die auf telegramm
veröffentlicht wurden
ukraine hat sich am abend auch
bundeskanzler scholz geäußert als er
sich im zdf den fragen von bürgerinnen
und bürgern gestellt hat dabei ging es
unter anderem darum wie lange die
solidarität wird der ukraine anhalten
werde angesichts steigender preise in
deutschland
ich glaube dass das sehr lange möglich
sein wird und dass wir so lange wie es
notwendig ist die solidarität mit der
ukraine aus deutschland heraus
aufrechterhalten können ich glaube dass
wir da als bürgern und bürger dieses
landes das tun werden wozu wir auch
unser selbst wegen verpflichtet sind
nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit um die an land
ringt nicht einfach mit gewalt
untergraben werden können und dass
bundeskanzler scholz sonst noch zu den
themen krieg corona und klima gesagt hat
wenn wir gleich im anschluss hier bei
maybrit illner
der bundestag hat heute ein
umfangreiches gesetzespaket zum ausbau
erneuerbarer energien beschlossen unter
anderem soll bis 2030 80 prozent des in
deutschland erzeugten stroms aus
klimafreundlichen quellen wie sonne
wasser oder wind stammen um das ziel zu
erreichen sollen zwei prozent der
gesamten landesfläche für windräder
ausgewiesen werden zur stunde
entscheidet der bundestag außerdem
darüber ob wieder mehr kohle werke
zeitlich befristet ans netz gehen dürfen
damit soll gas im mangel fall schneller
ersetzt werden dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit werde ataman ist neuer
bundesbeauftragter für
antidiskriminierung eine mehrheit im
bundestag stimmte für die 42 jährige
politologin und publizistin hat der mann
ist die erste vom parlament gewählte
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte an der
personalie hatte es im vorfeld scharfe
kritik gegeben union fdp und auch
einzelne vertreter der regierungspartei
fdp hatten ataman die eignung für das
amt abgesprochen und werfen ihr unter
anderem vor zu polarisieren und zu
spalten
fast vier jahre nach dem einsturz der
moore an die brücke mit 43 toten hat
heute in genua der gerichtsprozess
begonnen angeklagt sind 59 personen
darunter vertreter des
autobahnbetreibers und ex mitarbeiter
des italienischen
infrastrukturministeriums sie sollen für
wartungsmängel an der brücke
verantwortlich gewesen sein die moore an
die brücke war am 14 august 2008 10
eingestürzt dabei wurden dutzende
fahrzeuge in die tiefe gerissen
kennen sie ihre
wahlkreisabgeordneten und hat ein
kandidat oder kandidatinnen den
ausschlag dafür gegeben wie sie bei der
bundestagswahl ihre erststimme vergaben
hat eine person sie vielleicht sogar so
überzeugt dass sie ihr die stimme gaben
obwohl deren partei eigentlich nicht die
ist der sie sich am nächsten fühlen
falls sie sagen ja für mich ist die
persönlichkeit der wahlkreiskandidaten
bei der erststimme wichtig dann ist das
ein argument gegen die wahlrechtsreform
die die ampel koalition auf den weg
bringen will falls sie aber sagen ich
kenne kaum die namen die spielen beim
einer wahlentscheidung eigentlich keine
rolle wäre das ein argument für die
reformpläne worum es dabei geht und
warum darüber so erbittert gestritten
wird erläutert bernd benthin
wenn robert veerkamp sich aufmacht das
wahlrecht zu ändern dann läuft er vorbei
an all den folgen die das aktuell alle
wahlrecht hat am zusätzlichen neuen
bürogebäude für die zusätzlichen neuen
abgeordneten im bundestag der noch nie
so voll noch nie so teuer war das
problem des jetzigen wahlrecht ist es
dass die gefahr eines übergroßen nicht
mehr arbeitsfähigen bundestages bestehen
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiges
signal an die wählerinnen und wähler ist
dass der bundestag an sich selbst auch
etwas andere form und fortschritt
schafft was er ja vielen anderen
menschen mit vielen anderen reform auch
ab verlangt
regelmäßig donnerstags trifft sich die
wahl rechtskommission
diskutiert brütet streitet über neue
modelle alles online übertragen heute an
diesem donnerstag gibt die kommission
eine empfehlung ab das ist eine
vorentscheidung die ampel fraktionen
haben rückenwind gegeben für diesen
vorschlag deswegen wird auf der basis
dieses vorschlags dieser empfehlung im
september das gesetzgebungsverfahren
beginnen und ich gehe davon aus auch im
dezember noch diesen jahres
abgeschlossen werden der plan sieht
folgendes vor nach wie vor werden 299
sitze nachdem partei ergebnis also der
zweitstimme vergeben ebenfalls 299 sitze
gehen an die wahlkreis gewinner gewählt
mit der erststimme das neue wenn der
gewinn des wahlkreises nicht durch das
partei ergebnis im bundesland gedeckt
ist kriegt der gewinner den wahlkreis
nicht stattdessen könnte er zum beispiel
an den zweit oder dritt platzierten
gehen der oder die das nötige partei
ergebnis mitbringt
wahlkreis gewinner die ihren wahlkreis
da nicht kriegen ist das denn
vermittelbar wir haben ja einen sich
verändern das parteiensystem in dem der
erste oder die erste kandidatin in einem
wahlkreis oftmals nur 20 22 25 prozent
der erststimmen bekommen da davon zu
sprechen dass alleine die relative
mehrheit bei um die 20 prozent der
richtige wahl kreisvertreter
das ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß
die fraktionen von spd fdp und grünen
haben den vorschlag diskutiert und sind
mehrheitlich dafür linke und union
lehnen ihn ab vor allem die csu läuft
sturm wohl auch weil sie bislang in
bayern fast alle wahlkreise holt klar
ist dass wenn die ampel einen
verfassungswidrigen vorschlag
beschließen wird das was sie zurzeit
plant ist klar verfassungswidrig dann
werden wir umgehend klage beim
verfassungsgericht einleiten dagegen ein
neues wahlrecht verkleinert verständlich
verfassungsgerecht wäre ein signal für
die reformfähigkeit des bundestages und
für die fähigkeit zum verzicht
[Musik]
pandemie krieg inflation eine inflation
wie es in deutschland seit jahrzehnten
nicht gab und jene am härtesten trifft
die auch vorher schon scharf rechnen
mussten der paritätische
wohlfahrtsverband waren das die
armutsquote hierzulande noch nie so hoch
war wie in den beiden pandemie jahren
die pandemie traf zwar vor allem
erwerbstätigen insbesondere
selbstständige doch steigende
lebensmittelpreise und die zu
erwartenden heizkosten im kommenden
winter bekommen auch hartz 4 empfänger
und senioren mit schmale rente oder
grundsicherung betört zu spüren malin
ihlau berichtet
agnes hasenjäger ist derzeit immer auf
der suche nach lebensmitteln die
günstiger sind als beim discounter da
sind ihr die preise schon zu hoch einst
hat sie studiert auf lehramt wegen ihres
behinderten kindes konnte sie den beruf
nie ausüben bis zur rente arbeitete sie
teilzeit in einem labor deswegen fällt
ihre rente nicht gerade hoch aus sie
lebt an der armutsgrenze ich habe immer
gedacht mit meiner kleinen rente gerade
904 euro komme ich in etwa hin weil ich
eine günstige miete habe im moment geht
es noch weil ich von kindheit gelernt
habe mit wenig geld auszukommen und so
weiter an euch und wenig neue klamotten
oder sonst irgendwie aber was kommt noch
dass wahrscheinlich und dass es eben
miete und energie ist das was einem am
meisten angst braucht oder sorge die
inflation und die steigenden
energiepreise treffen die 72-jährige
genau so wie die die mit wenig geld
auskommen müssen deswegen findet sie es
besonders unfair dass rentner vom
energie geld der bundesregierung eine
milliarden schweren entlastungspaket
ausgeschlossen wurden durch die
steigenden lebensmittelpreise ist das
leben vieler rentner härter geworden der
anderen bei den tafeln ist in diesen
tagen immens ich bin alleinerziehend und
ich finde die preis an den
preiserhöhungen also enorm und die
inflation auf wir haben inflation von
sieben bis acht prozent das ist
wahnsinnig hoch und ja man ist sonst so
ganz halbwegs über die runden gekommen
ich bin frührentnerin und ja es ist
schwierig ist schwierig geworden
nadja und dinis leben zusammen beziehen
beide hartz4 sie bekommen außerdem noch
das energie geld der bundesregierung
doch das geld reicht nicht ohne die
lebensmittel der tafel wissen sie nicht
wie sie über die runden kommen sollen
sehr schwer alles man weiß teilweise gar
nicht mehr wie bei dem monat über
hinkommen soll man muss an allen ecken
sparen gruppen dass man es irgendwie
hinkriegt wir haben jetzt mitte des
monats sie ist ganz scheiße aus ende des
monats ist kaum rostock oder gar nichts
+ stromkosten erwarten wir auch noch
drauf was da noch auf uns zukommt na
also man darf darüber nachdenken
sozialverbände klagen es gebe zu wenig
unterstützung für geringverdienende für
rentner für alle die von der
grundsicherung leben
die menschen hier zum beispiel
arbeitslosengeld 2 bekommen die brauchen
einfach einen zuschlag wir werden aber
auch im bereich des niedriglohnsektors
werden wir aufstockungen finanzieren
müssen die menschen werben das sonst
nicht stemmen können agnes hasenjäger
hat ihr leben lang gearbeitet trotzdem
bekommt sie weniger als 1000 euro rente
im monat schon früher musste sie immer
aufs geld achten es war kein einfaches
leben
ich weiß als mein sohn erwachsen war
dass er sagte so ärgerlich wie ich
aufgewachsen bin mich sind nicht dass
meine kinder so aufwachsen müsste das
hat mich hart getroffen was sie jetzt
trifft ist die ständige sorge vor der
nächsten rechnung die sie nicht zahlen
kann eine sorge die sie teilt mit knapp
2,5 millionen rentner in deutschland die
wenig haben
und jetzt noch machen damit wird schafft
abhängigkeiten abbauen das ist gerade
das große thema bei der energie aber
auch in vielen anderen bereichen will
die wirtschaft dringend unabhängiger von
anderen ländern werden vw ist dabei
heute einen wichtigen schritt gegangen
frank bethmann und hat in salzgitter den
grundstein für seine erste
batteriezellen fabrik gelegt was
bedeutet dieser schritt für den
autobauer
letztendlich ist es das ergebnis eines
radikalen umdenkens noch vor jahren
hielten alle deutschen autobauer
batteriezellen für eine ware die man aus
asien zu kaufen könne das hörte sich
heute bei der feierlichen
grundsteinlegung von vw chef herbert
diess ganz anders an die batterie wird
neben der software der große werttreiber
im auto und deshalb geben wir sie nicht
aus der hand der dax-konzern hat großes
vor das milliarden-projekt salz giga nur
ein erster schritt blaupause für weitere
zell fabriken von vw in ganz europa
salzgitter aber steht für das erwachen
der deutschen autobauer für den einstieg
in die elektrische massenfertigung für
die politik bedeutet der heutige tag
dass der automobile wandel in
deutschland gelingen kann dass es vor
allem gelingen kann sich von
gefährlichen abhängigkeiten zu lösen
spätestens die korona pandemie und auch
russlands brutale angriff auf die
ukraine machten klar die abhängigkeit
von weltweiten lieferketten bedeutet auf
manchen strategischen feldern ein großes
risiko ein zu großes risiko doch zur
wahrheit gehört auch ohne fremde hilfe
wäre die salzgitter derzeit gar nicht
möglich beim bau der fabrik
greift dem volkswagen konzern
ausgerechnet ein technologiepartner aus
china unter die arme vielen dank für
diese anordnungen
um gas zu sparen will deutschlands
größter wohnungskonzern wo novia nachts
die heiztemperatur in seinen immobilien
herunterdrehen zwischen 23 und 6 uhr
sollen die gas zentralheizungen auf 17
grad eingestellt werden die versorgung
mit warmem wasser sei dabei nicht
betroffen betont der konzern rund 55
prozent der heizungen in den bono via
beständen werden mit gas versorgt
das neun euro ticket zeigt wirkung im
juni sind deutlich mehr menschen bahn
gefahren das ist das ergebnis einer
erhebung des statistischen bundesamts im
vergleich mit dem juni 2009 10 vor der
korona pandemie liegt das plus bei 42
prozent besonders viele menschen nutzen
den zug für kürzere und mittlere
strecken im straßenverkehr war dagegen
laut den statistikern etwas weniger los
zahlen stützen sich auf eine auswertung
von mobilfunkdaten
zum sport und damit zur frauenfußball wm
in england wird morgen auch die deutsche
nationalelf erstmals auf dem platz
stehen wird heute also das letzte
training und großer optimismus bei
bundestrainerin martina voss-tecklenburg
wo der gegner kein leichter ist nämlich
vize europameister dänemark 21 uhr
geht's morgen los zu sehen hier im zdf
tennisprofi rafael nadal kann wegen
einer bauchmuskelverletzung nicht am
wimbledon-halbfinale teilnehmen das gab
der 36 jährige spanier am abend bei
einer pressekonferenz bekannt er habe
einen riss im bauchmuskel user
voraussichtlich drei bis vier wochen
aussetzen erklärte nadal der australier
nick series zieht jetzt automatisch ins
finale des grand-slam-turniers ein
und wir bleiben noch einen wimbledon für
tatjana maria ist da heute auch ein
traum geplatzt sie stand ja kurz davor
ins finale einzuziehen was eine
sensation gewesen wäre ein ganz
besonderes comeback hat aber nicht
sollen sein trotzdem waren das für die
deutsche 2 tolle wochen in wimbledon
großes tennis berichtet aris donzelli
eine umarmung unter freundinnen ein
sichtlich ergriffener ehemann der
siegerin und eine besondere geste von
monster würden den publikumsjubel auf
dem ehrwürdigen center court mit erna
maria teilt das war ihre moment und sie
wollte trotzdem mit mir zusammen den
genießen deswegen war es auf alle fälle
was besonderes und ich meine thesen der
unglaubliche personen und ich bin auch
happy für sie dass sie jetzt in dem
finale ist und ich hoffe dass dies am
ende gewinnen kann 14 uhr 30 am mittag
der gang zum centre court hat jana
marias blickfeld links und rechts auf
bildern tafeln von siegerinnen und
siegern ein unvergesslicher eindruck
nach fast 14 tagen wimbledon
für uns unglaublich dass wir das alles
als familie leben konnten und dass ich
hier im halbfinale stand mit meinen zwei
kindern
wenn mir das jemand vor einem jahr
gesagt hätte er ist vielleicht nicht
geglaubt wie schon in den begegnungen
davor versucht hat jana maria ihre
gegnerin zu überraschen das gelingt dem
ersten satz gegen uns ja boer nicht oft
genug
zu dominant präsentiert sich die nummer
zwei der welt aus tunesien die bekannt
ist für ihr ballgefühl und das situative
spiel
die favoritin gewinnt den ersten
durchgang sechs zu zwei
trotzdem gelingt es der 34 jahre alten
deutschen das match zu drehen endlich
fruchten ihrer rhythmus brecher wie
dieser stopp zeigt logische folge
satzausgleich 623
[Applaus]
kann sie dann so ein vater sie mir
einfach nicht mehr wirklich viele punkte
geschenkt hat und dann hat sie auch
verdient gewonnen am ende und erreicht
mit 6 2 3 6 und 6 2 1 zum ersten mal ein
grand slam finale ein besonderer erfolg
für das poster girl der arabischen und
afrikanischen frauen welt
das war es von uns und jetzt wie schon
angekündigt der bundeskanzler im
bürgergespräch bei maybrit illner und
unser heute-journal update gibt es gegen
0.50 mit christopher wehrmann das morgen
auf wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]
schon genannt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ganz frisch die kopernikus
daten vom letzten monat also der juni
und der ist auf dem dritten platz
gelandet ist es also global der
drittwärmste juni und man sieht auch
viele rote vielleicht das bedeutet es
war deutlich zu warm die
temperaturabweichung ist also positiv
vor allem über europa und da hat sich
quasi die hitze manifestiert in den
durchschnitts daten für den juni und sie
sehen hier ganz klar richtung italien
spanien und frankreich deutschland bis
nach skandinavien überall deutlich zu
warm gewesen und die nächste hitzewelle
die baut sich allmählich auf über
spanien die wird dann später frankreich
erreichen ob sie dann zu uns kommt ist
noch nicht ganz klar in der nacht gibt
es schauer und gewitter nach osten hin
dass lässt allmählich nach im südosten
da ist es noch länger nass mit gewittern
teilweise im westen lockert es auf bei
tiefsten temperaturen dort um 9 grad und
15 grad an der ostsee morgen gibt es
dort dann also an der ostsee schauer und
richtung erzgebirge regnet es bei
dichten wolken im süden lässt es bald
nach sonst viel sonnenschein richtung
oberrhein bei höchsten temperaturen von
gut 18 grad an den alpen und am wärmsten
ganz im westen bei 26 grad am samstag
vor allem im nordosten schauer
temperaturen bis 27 grad und danach
liegt es regnet es nur noch ganz wenig
ein schöner abend